Okay we’re going to be looking today at copper.
This is something looking back at the old
video, it’s a short video and there isn’t
any experimentation in it so I thought we’d
do something a bit practical.
Copper is an element which people are very
familiar with because it’s such a characteristic
coloured metal, sort of reddish colour, though
it gets darker when oxide forms. But it’s
quite a soft metal and you can cut it quite
easily if you have a cutter like this which
has steel blades, it will just dig into the
metal and it should just cut off. When you
cut the metal you get this very nice, shiny,
fresh surface coloured just like copper.
This is a ball of copper, copper metal. As
you might imagine it’s a ball of metal so
therefore it is quite dense and heavy. I mean
it’s not as dense as, I think Steve told
me this morning, that if we had a ball this
size of plutonium he told me it would weigh
about a kilo and a half so he thought. So
it’s not quite as heavy as that but still
it’s pretty heavy and dense.
So this is a very, very nice sample of very
fine copper wire. So the copper wire here
is, what width is this? This is… phew! Point
zero, I’m not even going to…that’s just
too small, so it’s point one of a millimetre.
So inside the beaker we’ve got a solution
called sodium potassium tartrate, so no copper
in there at the moment. We’re going to introduce
that through this. This is a solution of copper
sulphate.
Copper is very popular for architectural use
because if you put it on the roofs of buildings
it then reacts, particularly with carbon dioxide
in the air, to give a very nice green colour.
First of all though we need to heat this to
about 50°C, and to the sodium potassium
tartrate we need to add some very weak, hydrogen
peroxide so this is only 3% hydrogen peroxide,
so in it goes. We need to make sure they mix
together which is why there’s a stirring
bar at the bottom there stirring away. Okay
so that’s stirring nicely, so as I said sodium
potassium tartrate and hydrogen peroxide and
we need to add only one mill so that’s 1cm3
of the copper sulphate.
The copper wire here is very, very high grade,
this is grade one copper wire and it’s point
one of a millimetre in diameter and you can
see the wonderful copperas lustre coming off
the side there.
What do you mean by grade one copper?
So this is very high purity, this is like
99.99% copper, used for electronics fabrications
and high quality research samples.
It’s also used for electrical wiring, in
fact it’s used so much that in a country
like the UK each person has about 175 kilos
of copper associated with each person, in
the piping, the wiring and so on. The problem
is that in many other countries, for example
in China, people have very much less copper
associated with them, there isn’t so much
electrical wiring in rural parts of China.
And if everybody in China had the same amount
of copper associated with them as those in
England or America or Canada there wouldn’t
be enough copper in all the known deposits
around the world.
Copper is actually necessary for life, plants
and animals use copper. But actually you can
have a disease called Wilson’s disease which
basically your body can’t metabolise copper
properly, it’s actually an inherited disease.
Ready? What’s going on there is it’s producing
a lot of gas so it’s reacting to form a complex.
And it’s going from the potassium tartrate
complex there to well, its producing carbon
dioxide and oxygen, mainly oxygen gas is being
produced which is why you’re seeing the fizzing.
And it’s become copper oxide, cuprous oxide
actually.
Copper is found as a metal lying around in
various places in the world. I believe the
name came from the island of Cyprus in the
middle of the Mediterranean, but copper has
always been know even in pre-historic times
people found small amounts of copper. But
as we use more and more copper people have
had to dig deeper and deeper mines. The mine
in Chile where those very brave miners were
entombed for more than two months and then
rescued was a copper mine. And to get the
metal that we need we’re going to have to
go deeper and deeper and deeper into the earth.
So what we’ve got in there now is cuprous
oxide it’s copper 1 oxide. And it’s actually
gone from what was a kind of clear see-through,
all right it’s got a colour on it, but see-through
solution to something that’s very cloudy.
So what we’ve got there is a precipitate
of copper oxide.
Copper is very good because it has very high
thermal and electrical conductivity. What
that means is that heat flows through it very
well and also electricity. If you make wires
for electrical transmission out of copper,
when the electricity goes through them you
get very much less heating than say if you
made the wires out of iron, and all this heating
is of course lost energy. You’d do even better
if you made the wires out of silver, but silver
is too expensive.
OK. So let’s see if we can change this reaction
back. So at the moment it started out as being
about 50°C and it’s shot up to about 63°C,
I imagine it was even hotter than that when
it originally changed colour. So we’ll see
if we can take it back, I’ll put that back
in.
I actually bought this from the British Geological
Survey which is just down the road from here,
I think it is in Keyworth I think. And I just
saw this and it was a Christmas present from
my husband and I picked it out. I just think
it’s really cool actually.
What did your husband think of getting that
as a Christmas present?
He knows what I’m like! So he buys these
things for me he knows I’m a bit of a magpie,
I like to collect shiny things, and pretty
things, that’s my copper.
So the colour is gradually changing, it’s
gone from orange and now kind of a murky yellow.
You can see it’s kind of green now. And again
a gradual change, it wasn’t a sudden spontaneous
straight back to being blue and see-through,
you know clear. Now we’ve got back to that
clear solution. And again you can see on the
stirrer bar all the bubbles of the oxygen,
little bit of C02 forming on that.
Most organisms, you and me, use iron in our
blood to transport oxygen, that’s what makes
our blood red. But in some sorts of crustaceans,
crabs and lobsters, they’re different they
use copper. They use a compound called hemocyanin,
it’s a blue compound of copper. Cyanine is
some classical word for blue. So they really
have blue blood. And these hemocyanin use
two atoms of copper in each molecule to transport
the oxygen around the body of the crab or
lobster. But it’s not nearly as good as haemoglobin,
so if you start running after a crab or lobster
it quickly gets tired compared to running
after a rabbit or something like that, which
can keep going faster than you can.